on va plus loin avec à mes côtés
gauthier rybinski la rédaction de france
24 jean gauthier gros fun et face à vous
ce soir j'ai eu plaisir à coeur françois
durpaire historien je rappelle un
françois le titre de la bd qui est sorti
la semaine dernière avec elle et dessins
de farid boudjellal elysées avec un z
comme zemmour vous suivez la campagne
d'eric zemmour et puis en parallèle le
destin de réfugiés qui tentent de gagner
la france exactement même une cousine
qui s'appelle saïda zemmour s 15 aides
qu'ils aident à avoir avec celui non sur
les cards assurément rien à se dire a
pas de ruée vers l'eau vers l'occident
vers l'ouest ça n'a rien à voir et pour
la petite histoire c'est vrai que la
campagne de pub a échoué cause de ça on
a pensé que le bon éditeur avait voulu
rendre hommage aux russes s'étaient pas
du tout le cas alors ça tient là on ne
compte plus justement les attaques
contre les civils en ukraine hier une
frappe a détruit un théâtre dans lequel
s'étaient réfugiés d'après des ong 500 à
800 civils dont on est toujours sans
nouvelles et ce malgré vous le voyez des
signaux clairs sans ces alertes et
l'armée russe aujourd'hui un centre
culturel et une école ont été pris pour
cible cette fois près de kharkiv la
ville assiégée et face à ce qui semble
bien s'apparenter à une succession de
crimes de guerre volodymyr zelensky lui
ne cesse d'alerter les opinions
publiques occidentales
dans la matinée ils étaient en
visioconférence devant le bundestag le
parlement allemand ont l'écoutent suivi
du discours assez similaire hier à
l'adresse cette fois du congrès
américain
pour qu'un nouveau mur ne soit pas
érigés en ce moment et pour que rien
n'arrive d'irrémédiable pour longtemps
je m'adresse à vous et je vous dis nous
avons besoin de votre aide
l'europe aussi en a besoin l'europe n'y
survivra pas et ces valeurs non plus
en tant que leader de ma nation je
m'adresse au président biden
vous êtes le leader d'une nation de
votre grande nation
je souhaite que vous soyez le leader du
monde
être le leader du monde c'est être le
leader de la paix
des prises de paroles assez similaire un
tant sur le fond que sur la forme
françois zelensky appuie là où ça fait
mal il a compris où se logent la
mauvaise conscience occidentale
exactement il arrive de manière
extrêmement habile à mélanger à mêler la
flatterie et l'exigence vous êtes joe
biden un formidable leader mais si vous
êtes un lidl falloir que vous accédiez
un certain nombre de mes demandes
il avait critiqué les allemands vous
nous envoyez que des casques il leur
parle de leur histoire et en particulier
du mur il sait s'adapter devant le
congrès il a parlé aux américains
du discours de martin luther king i have
a dream vous imaginez quand même dire
aux américains la cause ukrainienne est
à peu près semblable à la cause de
l'antiracisme américain faut quand même
le faire unir ces deux histoires là il
leur a parlé du 11 septembre donc il a
cette capacité finalement à faire que la
crise ukrainienne n'est pas une affaire
géopolitique pour l'allemand moyen pour
l'américain moyen parce que
c'est une affaire d'hommes ils les ruiz
la cause ukrainienne et c'est ça qui est
très très important et il met en échec
totalement la propagande vladimir
poutine pas dire poutine dit vous avez
affaire à des nazis et on voit gars
sympa courageux qui parle aux opinions
publiques via les congrès les parlement
canadien anglais à allemands américains
et il a aussi une intelligence de la
négociation dire que tu as eu par
exemple il est capable de dire mon plan
a c'est sécurisé le ciel parce que le
malheur vient du ciel mais j'ai aussi un
plan b le plan b c'est envoyez nous des
avions il sait que ni le plan a ni le
plan b n'est réaliste et donc son plan c
c'est à minima des sanctions beaucoup
plus ferme il sait que son plan c'est ça
va avancer et il obtient du congrès 14
milliards c'est à dire le double de ce
que le président américain avait demandé
buydens et sa prouesse pour dire un mot
c'est quand on pense aux ukrainiens en
occident on ne pense pas à eux on pense
à nous c'est ça la grande prouesse à ya
peut-être une faille quand même dans la
communication ukrainienne pour ceux qui
connaissent un petit peu les opinions
publiques et les sociétés civiles en
afrique ces images d'africains en
ukraine que se passe-t-il exactement
pour les africains en ukraine et que les
médias occidentaux en parle aussi peut
on en a parlé sur france 24 mais très
très peu dans les autres médias
occidentaux bien ça fait qu'en afrique
beaucoup se disent la cause ukrainien
dont c'est pas bien on sait pas bien
tant qu'on nous a pas dit ce qui était
vrai ce qui était faux et ce qui
effectivement les ukrainiens peuvent
passer la frontière et qu'ils sont
considérés ces étudiants nigériens comme
des réfugiés ou pas est ce qu'il ya du
racisme etc et il ya cette petite chose
qui fait que l'occident est uni derrière
henin ce qui met le monde entier attend
quand même des explications et merci le
rappeler effectivement françois gauthier
lorsqu'il parle de nouveaux murs ça ça
résonne forcément pour les allemands il
y avait une responsabilité historique
convoque pour eux zelensky à à rompre
avec leur pacifisme d'après guerre oui
parce que ce pacifisme et il était
justifié par l'histoire souvenons nous
qu'à une certaine époque des slogans
allemande de la nouvelle allemagne
c'était de dire l'allemagne doit
disparaître la france doit étendre ses
frontières jusqu'à la pologne avait un
slogan qui allaient dans ce sens là bon
maintenant ce qu'on voit bien
aujourd'hui c'est que ce pacifisme
allemands aussi vertueux et momentanée
ou en tout cas adéquat au moment utile
il est quelque chose aussi qui
correspondait à une vision de
l'allemagne c'est à dire se contenter
d'être un géant économique est un homme
politique et c'est à ce bas cela que
l'on peut mesurer d'ailleurs à l'aune de
cela on peut mesurer l'obsolescence
totale du matériel de la bonne ce faire
de l'armée allemande et que donc il y a
la volonté là aussi zelensky et frappe
fort parce qu'il dit vous voyez le mur
vous l'avez fait tomber mais voulait
fait tomber en fait ce mur est tombé
grâce à une multiplicité de facteurs
aussi bien à l'ouest de l'est et vous
avez cru et c'est ça qui est intéressant
il dit vous avez cru que l'histoire
était terminée que vous aviez gagné que
la vertu l'avait emporté sur le vice que
le bien laver emporte us sur le mal et
ça n'est pas vrai et vous avez cherché
les verges pour vous faire battre dit il
aux allemands avec le north stream 2 qui
est ce finalement ce que ce canal de
dépendance énergétique de l'allemagne
vis-à-vis de la russie donc c'est là
qu'il frappe fort maintenant par rapport
il faut 8 un mot je vous dis comment ça
a été reçue par ce que il ya eu un tollé
à l'issue de du du discours donc de
l'adresse de lenski au bundestag parce
que la vice présidente du bundestag a
voulu passer à l'ordre du jour normal et
évidemment parmi les députés ça a été
quelque chose de d'absolu moyen
acceptable ou non dit nous ne pouvons
pas nous contenter en substance je
résume de mobiliser de dépenser 100
milliards d'euros justement pour
remettre sur pied la bonne de ce faire
il n'en va pas que de l'argent ça va
beaucoup plus loin que ça et on aurait
attendu quelque chose de plus digne
après l'adresse du président ukrainien
ce faisant on le voit et lenski il
devient presque un acteur du jeu
politique dans un certain nombre de pays
c'est le cas notamment aux états unis où
son adresse à à joe biden a incarné le
rôle du leader du monde libre sonne
comme une injonction françois aux
oreilles des républicains que n'hésite
pas à pointer la faiblesse de deux de
leurs dirigeants exactement et quand
même d'un bout l'image on va parler des
républicains mais d'un mot l'image je
pense que la force au site zenasci c'est
vous avez vu c'est ce gars mal rasé sous
les bombes on sait qu'il a été acteur
qui jouait le président aujourd'hui
c'est un président qui sait jouer son
rôle d'acteur il a ce t-shirt les face
soit à des parlementaires allemands
choix des parlementaires américains qui
sont engoncés dans leurs vestes dans
leur cravate sur leurs chaises de
velours bleu et lui il est le leader
aujourd'hui la démocratie pour faire
simple maiden parle de démocratie mais
lui il incarne et il incarne pour le
peuple américain il incarne pour le
peuple allemand et il est celui qui dit
vous êtes hypocrite vous occidentaux
vous dites oui c'est formidable votre
combat et vous n'êtes pas prêt à mourir
et donc ça c'est quand même une force
incroyable force aussi du verbe on a
l'impression d'une repli réplique de
cinéma quand il dit moi j'ai pas besoin
j'ai besoin d'armes j'ai pas besoin de
chauffeurs à présent que tout ça était
gris à hollywood absolument prodigieux
d'un mot son instrumentalisation
instrumentalisation alors il ya deux
droite américaine il ya la première
droite américaine qui très clairement
est en train de rétropédaler beaucoup de
républicains qui se disent finalement on
a quand même été assez proche des
positions de donald trump c'est à dire
plutôt assez doux à l'égard de vladimir
poutine et aujourd'hui on critique joe
biden qu'en mettant trop mou à
l'encontre de vladimir poutine c'est
quand même une position extrêmement
paradoxal c'est celle de mitch mcconnell
par exemple le chef de la minorité
républicaine au sénat
quand même difficile à tenir ils parient
sur le fait que les opinions pas de
mémoire c'est même michael s'en vont on
va le voir cette capture d'écran sur un
site internet effectivement ou macpaint
dit il n'y a pas de place pour la une
quelconque indulgence envers poutine
nommé étant dit il ya un seul
républicain qui a soutenu la destitution
de donald trump je rappelle que la
destitution donald trump c'était ça
c'était lié à la suspension de l'aide
ukrainienne parce que les américains ont
entendu parler du cren c'était cette
fameuse affaire du fils de joe biden un
seul s'était mitt romney tous les autres
ils sont trempés là dedans donc dire
aujourd'hui c'est incroyable c'est une
découverte etc et puis il ya une autre
position de la nouvelle droite
américaine qui est pour le coup beaucoup
plus droit dans ses bottes qui
effectivement dit poutine c'est notre
héros il est autocratique sait très bien
où on a eu un putin américain qui
s'appelait donald rentes il est pour les
valeurs conservatrices il est contre
l'homosexualité
il est pour les valeurs familiales et
les contres multiculturalisme il est
pour l'identité pour le nationaliste
c'est nous c'est nous la nouvelle droite
américaine poutine et vous avez par
exemple tucker carlson qui survivent sur
12 le célèbre amiens mais ils comptent
plus que mike pence pour les américains
parce que quand vous êtes un
conservateur américain pour garder fox
news vous gardez carlson et vous avez un
gars avant le conflit qui vous dit il ya
un dictateur oui il s'appelle et un ski
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
la dmr poutine 01 ski c'est une
marionnette de ben hayden donc c'est un
ennemi de tous les conservateurs
américains
l'ukraine n'est pas une démocratie comme
si la russie l'été ça c'est ce que
carlson disait avant le conflit depuis
le conflit il dit quoi il dit là il
vient de dire que les quand même gros
steak news de moscou repris par par fox
news les etats-unis ont des laboratoires
en ukraine où se développent des armes
biologiques voilà et quand vous êtes à
conservateurs américains vous écoutez ça
il critique les sanctions à l'encontre
des oligarques russes en dix ans comme
inacceptables ils ont rien fait bon son
entourage devenir poutine mais ils n'ont
rien fait donc il ya envoyé ces deux
droites une droite qui se dédient et une
droite qui est droit dans ses bottes
continuer à soutenir poutine ça va
laisser des traces cette guerre en
ukraine gauthier justement dans un pays
comme les etats-unis dans ce qu'elle
révèle peut-être un retournement d'une
partie d'anciens rennais donald trump et
on le voit une droite notamment donald
trump lui même un qui dit bah finalement
poutine est un génie no 1 des mailles
watch si j'avais été là ils l'auraient
peut se serait le pape a même permis
néanmoins voilà il salue son son sa
dextérité sa stratégie oui ç'a toujours
été une grande surprise de constater
justement l'existence de ces deux droite
américaine dont celle dont vous venez de
parler à l'instant et f plus faible à
l'époque de donal logue mais j'avoue
qu'à voir vu un certain nombre de
justement de soutien de donald trump
être passé comme ça vers le kremlin
alors qu'eux ils ont été pour la plupart
quand même des anticommunistes virulent
pendant longtemps il y avait quelque
chose de surprenant mais au fond ce que
vous françois est en train de vous dire
c'est qu'il y a que cette droite
américaine une certaine droite
américaine elle est en train de rentrer
dans son bercail et idéologiques sont
marqués il est logique et l' axe du mal
est au fond la russie n'étant qu'une
qu'une héritière du communisme
soviétique et vladimir poutine guettant
vraiment toujours comme l'avait dit john
mccain qui l'avait dit j'ai regardé
vladmir poutine dans les yeux et j'ai vu
les trois est kgb ont la série pas
d'ailleurs quel oeil avait les deux
lettres et lequel avec la seule darcis
gauthier rybinski merci également à à
françois durpaire rester avec nous on se
retrouve dans une minute pour un nouveau
genre
[Musique]